Hello. Welcome to the lesson on How to Solve Problems. Solving problems is one
of the most important skills you can learn. And calling it skill is really an
understatement. Nearly everything you can do can be viewed as solving problems.
And improving as a problem solver is a lifelong challenge. One short lesson is
not going to be enough to make anyone an expert problem solver. But for this
lesson, we're going to, to look at some aspects of how to approach more
complicated programming problems. And hopefully, that will help you in solving
any problem that you're faced with from now on. But it doesn't really make sense
to talk about solving problems without thinking about particular problems. So,
we're going to look at a specific practice problem and talk about how I would go
about solving that. And our goal by looking at a particular problem is not just
to solve that particular problem, but to draw some general lessons about how we
can get better as problem solvers in general.